bella artisti ragazzi e benvenuto che
sono io sono parigi oggi siamo un po di
o deviati un po dalla copertina perché
vi spiego allora giorni si chiama granny
simulator e io stesso mi sono fatto
fregare perché sono segreti gioco amato
da tutti con la vecchia che ti picchia e
invece non è quello è grandissimo e come
una nonna vera una nonna che sembra
michael scofield di prison break che
deve fuggire e niente quindi andiamo sul
single player vediamo dovrebbe essere un
gioco anche carino perché ci sono due
livelli il terzo comini sul perché ha
detto ah beh faccia un gioco ma c'è poca
roba perché tanto non sono sicuri
neanche noi che magari fa schifo quindi
facevano è poco non ho mai lo compro
subito datemi mamma ce l'hai 5 euro
no no fermi oggi ho visto l'epicità in
un secondo visto evita energia cento
anche io sono michael scofield mia nonna
star huber stava pulendo la mia stanza
sono morto
ho sbattuto la testa cos'è successo
aiuti che gioco è male scusatemi che non
ho capito fuchao ma e ho capito niente
una morto ma cos'è mare gioco è
affacciato un calcio ma come ho capito
lei io devo ammazzare lei ma non ti
parma sesto ma scusa guarda ho fatto io
devo fare fuori lei prima che completi
la sua la sua quest capito quindi le sue
il suo obiettivo era poi ripulirmi la
stanza e l'ha fatto per set to interesse
ok mano è ok
l'ho presa cosa me ne faccio vabbè ma
questo è successo ma perché perché vi è
piaciuto qui mica nove ragazzi gioco
dell'anno famme capì ci sono delle
chiavi come entrò in casa mi scusi mia
nonna ma sul calcio fortissimo io trovo
le chiavi poi qualcosa servono se chiavi
o che non è possibile
ok votato un coltello non così non
contendo no premio premio lo lanciò
posso lanciare il coltello a gremio che
perfetto zia l'ho colpita come gli ho
tolto pochissimo e meloni dai che ti
picchio
mi sa che non me lo ridà ragazzi questo
gioco lo studieranno nelle scuole ve lo
dico
io che io prevedo il futuro ogni tanto
lo faccio quindi ci sono vari oggetti
per far del male a grani tipo la
bottiglia che la posso dire ma devo
tirarla io ero le cose a mia nonna ciao
madonna che te la posso prendere il
coltello ancora conficcato qui non lo
fosse prima per tienitelo regalo non
fate queste cose alla nonna ragazza che
se questo in gioco vinto a farmi capire
un attimo se posso prendere questa roba
qua che non so cosa sia però non ha
dolore gal ottieni buon natale e un
gioco bellissimo amelia è così e ci sono
più scaturì martello va bene
nonna scusami se mi si è rotto il
clementoni il computerino stupido è
niente sono stupito anche io non ha per
favore non pulire la tua stanza e poi un
casino non puri non pulire madonna non
credo sia temi di fendi però non sono
anche come possa fare il contrario
mamma ottimo ma tratto recupera video
sbaglio genio non ora che la colpisco ai
mori con la essence muore io voglio
vedere flap a picco demonio che botta
ragazzi stiamo giocando all'attacco dei
giganti in realtà 57 dvd ragazzi non va
giù mai ci mettono una vita per farla
fuori questo martello unque a bere ed
ebook e bellitta io voglio dare i soldi
a chi ti ha fatto solo gioco che basta
tirarmi caci il mio dio
ma c'è una questa casa ai pregiudicati e
longboard ci sono le porte nascoste
nelle porte una torcia mio dio
vabbè sono diventato in eroi di league
of legends ma scusami nonna in un
secondo più grande sta provando a
trovare le sue cure per il cuore
tieni che detto l'ho trovata io porca
vacca nell'occhio
la donna che botta no no no no no
nell'occhio nella bocca semi si sta
formando un cannone nonna aia non la mia
mi ha messo fuori dai giochi
definitivamente ma non c'è aperte aperta
28 di vita attenzione tanto della mia
energia sempre cento non c'è
sai perché sono un po immortale prove
dove ci sono altre torce li proviamo
usare quelle per farla fuori
no non a non entrare non entrare un
entrare cioè il bastone integrato nella
testa quella per vedere per andare in
giro spetta non aspetta aspetta porco
demonio le torce sarko beni si occuperà
la vita lo vedi era 20 prima porca vacca
non farle trovare le medicazioni demonio
occhi ai premi l'altro blindato mentre a
terra veloce 33 ragazzi mamma mia
sarebbe già morta non si fosse curata
agr eni a madonna del successo becca
pure questo sì vabbè tanto ma come fare
ad occuparsi così tanta vita ma dai che
fastidio
basta il taser come bastati radicati
come trovato un taser
mamma mia si limita il piatto solo di
testa è fortissimo anche la pentola
teoricamente di questa volta non si è
fatto nulla però ragazzi a 26
farò mai ok 4 agli artigli era la teiera
dei report brevissimo riuscissi a
trovare una roba che fa male sarei a
posto guarda mirá mirá già porco demonio
mancata bloccata lì tra l'altro presa a
due di vita dai però gen
c'è della roba che quella bottiglia a
bottiglia la faccio fuori con la
bottiglia spetta tra l'europa che gioco
ai ragazzi il pro bowl family friendly
alma proprio famille femmili famiglia
non friendly amico con la nonna
dobbiamo fare il capitolo ii livello 2
bellissimo difficile pero bello allora
vitale la nonna cento adesso sappiamo
cosa fare 15 già subito all'inizio mi
sono attaccato sto leccando il quadro
elettrico non è proprio il massimo rosa
è amico mio nokia ragazzo inventato
buona visibilità che non si vedeva
niente se no
positive del miglio era completamente
buio quando non le chiavi
mia nonna già fatto qualcosa mentre un
in pausa 5 pieno di roba da prendere
quindi dobbiamo fare solo rob e
dall'altra parte quello ricordare che la
stanza dove il si aprono le scatole che
porta siamo massimo di sopra il posto lo
stesso teoricamente quindi devo fare le
stesse cose ma di notte
eccola ma è l'armadio cosa ci fai un
armadio nonna cosa ci fai new york
nordio 16 elevato tantissimo potrà
prender la bomba corri corri corri a
prendere la bomba è ora di usare le
maniere forti
non la sta provando a trovare la
lanterna nel basement prendi due eccola
qua la lanterna non ha tieni cava ha
apposto bene gli ho levato 25 questa
personale basta un po di più e per vasco
40 una moto segano cos'è non raga ferma
al click
ok un calibro mamma no no no parco
lemonia poche male ecco la lanterna
found volta a 48 di vita si è recuperato
un sacco
la teiera sta fuori a chi ci ha fatto
boom la the year è forte una delle porte
per gli ha subito l'abbiamo fatta raga
quasi cav h filiera
10 vita non c'era niente non ci credo
pentolaccia teoricamente questo è il
colpo di grazia proprio lui è stato il
gioco propone io mi sono emozionato qui
sta il cuore mi ha emozionato cuore è
una parte importante delle persone
tranne per la norma che tanto serve
quindi ragazzuoli spero vi sia piaciuto
e io come al solito vi saluto vi
ringrazio per aver visto il video non
era felice era semi non lo so cos'è
lasciate un bel life che meglio vi
iscrivetevi al canale schiacciata anche
la bellissima campanella riprovi vicino
al tas iscritti che serve per fare
arrivare le notifiche quando carico un
video che sono non lo vedete è noi come
sempre ci rivediamo al prossimo video da
ragazzi
[Musica]